on this episode I talk about box of the
Month Club ideas Facebook video versus
YouTube and how I got food poisoning
this morning you ask questions and I
answer them this is the askgaryvee show
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 81 of
the askgaryvee show let me just say that
the two-week hiatus was something that
was really hardcore I really missed the
show vaynernation thank you so much for
all the tweets and the comments on
Instagram and the emails talking about
how much you missed the show I want you
to know I missed you guys so much that
this morning I had food poisoning uh-huh
and I rarely ever miss I mean I'm never
sick like this don't miss days and I had
to miss the entire morning I was knocked
out and the Mayo is texting me all
morning saying don't come in it's one of
those ironic days where I'm here to hold
a they're all pretty light weight
meetings we can push them to the end of
the week and I said no I've got to come
in and I've got to do episode 81 of the
askgaryvee show because people are
waiting and I couldn't disappoint so I
apologize for having my energy down a
little bit for episode 81 but India
let's get in to the shower Chris asks
you've done too long for Matt web shows
in a world where gurus advise keeping
online videos short and sweet
what gives Chris a couple things first
and foremost it's always very dangerous
to listen to the device of online
marketing gurus I think what gives is
very simply something that I think is
the right advice which is quality
Trump's everything right and so I
remember in 2007 being flown out to
Mountain View and Sunnyvale by Yahoo and
google to try to figure out what gives
with Wine Library TV now remember this
is eight years ago trying to figure out
why my show was doing so well
even though it was long and so the the
real answer was quite simple quality is
quality is quality if I'm able to put
out a 15 20 minute thirty minutes show
and I can captivate and hold the
audience well then it has a chance of
doing well if I can't then it won't I
mean it's not super complicated there
are plenty of [ __ ]
13 second videos there are plenty of
waste of time never get off the ground
one minute shows you will watch a three
hour avatar because it's good you will
not watch a 15-second commercial because
it's crap and so the length is not the
variable of the quality as a matter of
fact to break deke Rock's heart neither
is the sound or the lighting or the
production it is the message it is the
message it is the message I'm telling
you it's the message now do you rock has
come into my life and have made
everything much better so I do respect
the production more than I did in 2006 7
& 8
but the truth is for hit the fist pump
that he just put out behind the scenes
the bottom line is if he wasn't dealing
with this kind of quality all the
production he put out still wouldn't
matter paul asks can you provide insight
in how you nurtured your public speaking
shops besides just hustling on stage how
do you prepare for a talk have you ever
been nervous to speak publicly Paul
great question first of all ridiculously
rad picture d-roc show it again in love
with the drone just well completely
caught our attention great job you know
you know the truth is I hit the stage
somewhere in 2006 for the first first
time as somebody to listen to and it was
instantaneous it was love at first sight
I love the stage the stage loved me and
so obviously I've got a lot of practice
matter of fact I'm what really what I'm
struggling with more than anything right
now is the fact that I'm just getting
into such a rhythm I feel like I'm a
stand-up comic right that I have my kind
of talk and I take a lot of pride of
making it you know 8 to 15 minutes out
of an hour different based on the
audience but I want it to be 45 minutes
different but I'm in kind of a cadence
right now so obviously I've gotten
better my timing has gotten down
but I've never done anything like it's
kind of like this show right like one of
the things that I love about doing
meerkat behind the scenes now is that
people can see how little to no editing
there really is there is no real prep I
think my biggest secret is talk about
what you know you're good at right like
talk about stuff you know you know I try
not to answer questions about for
policy or currency or you notice I stay
away from Bitcoin or you know I don't
talk about the things I don't know right
I can view my opinion and at the end of
the day this show and everything else is
my opinion but boys that grounded and
really strong research and skill and
practitioner DNA I feel like my opinion
business matters because of the
execution I did to get there whereas my
opinion on everything else I have my
opinions on a lot of things but you know
they're not as grounded in as much
research the more intuitive which is
fine take them for what they are
you know what opinions are but I you
know I stick to what I know and that
helps me just stream I'm a good
communicator bye bye DNA and by staying
in my comfort zone in my lanes of
expertise and the places where I
actually spend my time honing my craft
it comes off very clean because it's
very natural because it is natural
Kelton asks what would be the best way
to sample healthy energy drinks out to a
thousand people by the end of the year
Kelton I took this question because I
want to give you a shout out and give
you exposure to my audience because I
appreciate your hustle on the flip side
your question is crap let me explain to
get a thousand people to pet try your
energy drink I don't know just go to a
crowded place outside and start pouring
I would have a thousand people try my
energy drink literally within eight
hours on a Saturday by going to Central
Park and maybe you live in some rural
area so get your ass into a car or a
train and find a crapload of people get
a goddamn stand and pour to a bunch of
little cups and you'll hit your thousand
in eight hours
[ __ ] question Gary its magician and
corporate entertainer David Orr now I
hear what's the deal with Facebook's
video push do you think they're going to
become a monetized video platform and
what does that mean for people who are
starting a YouTube show in the coming
weeks like I am thanks David it means
that first of all the answer question
yes it means for people starting YouTube
shows they should seriously start
considering starting Facebook shows now
that is people that actually have money
right because we're Facebook video gets
really valuable as when you start
spending two to five hundred dollars a
day
targeting audiences because you can
target
we've never seen before and so you know
look I think I think Facebook is a
massive it's already a massive
competitor to YouTube YouTube should
absolutely be concerned when you layer
the data listen I keep yelling about
this the data the data the data that
Facebook sits on top that allows you to
target against creates an ultimate
machine and you know I'm spending a ton
of time I'm looking at Andy no I'm not I
thought there was a me I'm trying to
look at Andy Kay right now on my team
who grows audience with me and and
Facebook video is at the top the tippy
top of our concern and and I think now
that they're showing viewcount and now
that they're embedded you know one of
the reasons I like using YouTube as it
shows perceptions reality how many views
it builds brand now that I can do the
same thing with Facebook my intentions
are to maybe even switch some manam I
but if you asked me if my primary embed
was Facebook video over YouTube video
six months from today on Gary Vaynerchuk
business videos I would say yes think
about that so it's a huge huge deal it
also I think competition breeds
innovation and so I'm excited because I
think YouTube gets scared a little bit
here or Google gets scared a little bit
here and will actually see better
quality innovation come out of YouTube
because they've been pretty stale for a
half decade in a lot of ways and I think
that they're gonna both push each other
now you've got live streaming video you
know video is king and we're living
through the picture revolution right
Instagram at the forefront but I think I
think video still has a long way to go
and we're living through it and I just
think there's more upside more on both
categories actually but I think Facebook
video is probably grossly underestimated
by the far majority of this audience
right now I think the upside is enormous
I myself am paying a ton of attention to
it
you know what that speaks Michele asks
what's your take on subscription box
services
Michelle first and foremost
congratulations that is an adorable
picture it just it's really cute and I
fully expect you and that little one to
send me a version of that picture ten
years from today since I put you on the
show and I'd like to see it so I'm
looking forward to being surprised and
trying to recall why it's happening ten
years from today big out shout out to
2025 the answer to your question box
services look I wrote one of the first
checks into Birchbox and was an angel
Wester in barkbox were incubating a
business here called faith box I'm a
very big fan of the subscription box
service I think it's the way people like
to buy we like to buy once and forget
about it
I think the good businesses because then
even when we get stuff we don't want we
don't cancel right away so you get an
extra two to five seven months worth of
business you know that's just the truth
and so I'm very bullish on them and I
think that there's innovation to be had
I think that right you know the box was
kind of the innovation all this is the
Month Club right it's just the basket of
the Month Club
so I actually I've been thinking for a
long time like what else can I fit in it
can it be like a balloon like can it be
like like like you know like peanut
balloon calm or like a balloon lands and
there's peanuts in it each month like I
feel like the mechanism the box itself
has some innovation around and I hope
that idea spurred a thought for somebody
and they start a huge million dollar
business because of it I definitely
think that there's a play there as far
as upping the hustle I would say you
know the birth of a new child is one of
the most remarkable important moments of
one's life and even though I'm 24/7 365
how so much like I talked about getting
plenty of sleep and vacations matter
it's what you do when you're awake I
wouldn't over stress the first you know
one to ten months depending on your DNA
I would really focus on laying the
foundation of a healthy relationship but
and lifestyle for your baby you've got
plenty of time to pick it back up unless
your maniac like me then I would just
say just a little less sleep and try to
prioritize your health and vitamins and
drink water and stuff like that and
don't eat weird food that makes you
throw up for seven hours
the next morning and that's it question
of the day
let's have india ask the question there
I like the on-the-spot stuff ship that
quickly don't give her time this is so
rewarding as look double switcheroo Alex
gets asked question today yes/no will
not accept that back to India back to
India back to India Jesus Christ I'll
take over take a picture of your home
screen on your phone right now and tweet
it to me and at garyvee I want to see
the apps that dominate your day so we
you know what I failed
nobody asked a question a day it was the
dictation of the day you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
wearing around her neck today what it
would that is not a scarf
I'm cold you know I'm always cold I know
I'm always hot that is not the beta test
meerkat okay I'm using the actual one
that's in the App Store so we should be
fine
a great job by founder and CEO meerkat
how many peeps in there 339 three nine
awesome cool